[Music]
straight ahead on law on crime daily
defendant kyle rittenhouse takes the
stand on august 25th of 2020 did you
come to downtown kenosha to look for
trouble no
the man accused of murdering two men and
injuring another breaks down while
testifying
there were
three
people right there
plus hear the heated exchange between
the judge and the prosecutor and the
trial in the death of ahmed arboree what
has happened in this case
is a lynching in the 21st century we're
live in georgia with the latest
developments in the trial later abused
and tortured members of the turpin
family speak out for the first time the
only word i know to call it is hell law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to log crime daily i'm
michael bryant in for brian buttfire who
is in georgia covering the ahmed arbory
case we'll hear from him soon also here
of course co-host terry austin is with
me and we begin with news out of
wisconsin as defendant kyle rittenhouse
takes the stand telling the jury why he
felt the need to shoot three men in
kenosha killing two of them law and
crimes angenette levy is here with the
dramatic moments from britton house's
testimony angenette
michael kyle rittenhouse told the jurors
that he worked in kenosha wisconsin and
on the night of august 25th 2020 he met
up with friends as they went to guard
some properties during the unrest there
now written house told the jurors also
that he was a police explorer and a
firefighter emt cadet with first aid
training he also worked as a lifeguard
he told some people that night he was an
emt but that turns out to not be true he
described what happened in the moments
leading up to his shooting of joseph
rosenbaum whom he said had threatened to
kill him and others threatening to cut
out their hearts he also described
shooting anthony huber and gage
grosskroots rittenhouse broke down while
answering a question about what happened
when he shot rosenbaum
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
um
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and there were
there were
three
people right there
[Music]
everybody that you shot at that night
you intended to kill
correct
i didn't intend to kill them i intended
to i intended to stop the people who
were attacking me
by killing them
i did what i had to do to stop the
person who was attacking me
now under cross-examination assistant
prosecutor thomas binger suggested that
rittenhouse has had quite a bit of time
to get his story straight which prompted
an objection from the defense and a
stern warning from judge bruce schroeder
you have also had the opportunity to
listen to the testimony of all
30-some witnesses that have testified in
this trial so far correct yes and after
all of that now you are telling us your
side of the story correct correct
he's commenting on my client's right to
remain silent
you know your honor i am making the
point that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story
to what has already been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation for you to talk
about the defendants silence
and that is and and in your right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but it better stop
and that wasn't the end of the warnings
from judge schroeder he scolded binger
again for trying to bring up the
comments that rittenhouse had made a
couple of weeks prior to this shooting
in which he said he wished he had had
his ar-15 as he was watching looters at
a pharmacy
mr richards absolutely correctly points
out that just hours ago i said i had
heard nothing in this trial to change
any of my rulings so why testimony are
on it pardon me that was before that
get brazen with me
uh
you knew very well
you
know very well that an attorney can't go
into these types of areas when the judge
has already ruled without asking outside
the presence of the jury to do so so
don't give me that
now the cross-examination continued well
after the lunch break for several hours
and the prosecution played a number of
videos from that night and suggested and
tried to get written house to admit that
he really had no reason to fear for his
life that evening and no reason to use a
gun to guard property
michael boy what a wild day in court
there aunt jeanette thank you we're
joined now by co-host terry austin also
criminal defense attorney julie
randleman julie let me start with you uh
kyle riddenhaus we saw him he broke down
on the stand
are you buying it do you think that was
a sincere emotion
god i hate being asked those questions
because i'm always so skeptical i mean
look there's some people that viewed it
and said it was amazing how quickly he
stopped crying once the jury left the
room um
look he's he's what 18 19 now i can only
imagine that there must be incredible
emotion getting on the stand for the
first time and talking about something
you know that he's
that he did that is so incredibly
horrific um i didn't see tears i don't
know that everyone cries and has tears
um i'm trying to be as open-minded as
possible um certainly i believed many of
the things he was saying as to whether
he was sincere with his tears i'm just
not sure i guess the jury will have to
decide that's exactly right it was a
moment that's for sure and terry there
was another moment or two when the judge
was yelling at the prosecution several
times not what you want to feel and see
and be part of if you're in the
courthouse how do you think the judge
handled the situation
actually michael i thought initially the
judge was fairly even-handed he does
have this odd way of explaining
objections to the jury but then when he
started yelling at bingor i thought it
was over the top there was actually one
point we heard it there where he
basically said don't be brazen with me
when finger was trying to explain the
basis of why he was doing this line of
questioning
and then i thought that you know at
another point the judge actually said
i'm not buying it you're not acting in
good faith essentially he is telling
that attorney you are lying and frankly
whether you agree with the line of
questioning or not
he was trying to give a good faith basis
for why he was going down that path and
if in fact the judge thought it should
be a mistrial he can say that but i
think to yell and scream from the bench
is really showing some bias thank god it
wasn't in front of the jury yeah he did
get close i'll tell you that and
jeannette it appeared that kyle
rittenhouse did have some support there
we saw his mom crying when he was so
emotional
yeah and you saw her there as he started
to break down she was crying quite a bit
there was a woman there with her arm
around her comforting her
in the courtroom and she cried a number
of times throughout the day as her son
testified even when he would start to
break down later in the day she became
very upset as well and she has raised a
great deal of money for him online to
pay for his defense well quite the drama
in court today thanks guys still ahead
on law and crime daily the fast-paced
trial of wisconsin versus kyle
rittenhouse continues
what shocking motion the defense made
midday today and how that could affect
the rest of the trial all of that and
more coming up next
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
we are going to make sure that we find
justice in this case the three men
charged will now stand trial i told him
stop stop stop till he hit me i had
nothing to do
there's nothing else i can do you're a
pacifier coming through not necessarily
that's my son that shot him i was in the
back of the truck
starting october 18th watch live capital
gavel coverage on the law and crime
network
[Music]
and welcome back to law and crime daily
we continue our coverage in wisconsin in
the murder trial of kyle rittenhouse a
shocking turn of events today the
defense moving for a mistrial all eyes
of course on kenosha today because kyle
rittenhouse took the stand
after he broke down during the defense
direct questioning cross-examination got
heated when assistant district attorney
thomas binger continued to press
rittenhouse with questions pointing out
the defendant had chosen to remain
silent after his arrest and at a midday
defense motion for a mistrial he cited
binger's repeated efforts to bring up
comments written house made several
weeks before the shootings
the defense is going to be making a
motion
for a mistrial what has happened in
in this this morning
was
two times
the state had commented on mr
rittenhouse's right to remain silent
the first time he was admonished by the
court the second time the court had the
jury leave
and re-admonished him on that
binge then fired back saying the
questions are fair game because
rittenhouse made comments to the press
ahead of the trial
the defendant has presented
interviews
to
at least one media source and at least
one online source
since his arrest
and
there have been questions about
that night there have been questions
about what he did
things like that
he has
decided probably on advice of council in
those circumstances not to
give a statement in the media about what
happened but he is talking about his
family life he's talking about his
friends he's talking about the
circumstances of the case he's talking
about how this has affected him and
things like that
so terry the defense makes a motion for
this mistrial really based on on two
grounds two issues so let me break this
up let me have you guys tag team this
start with you terry explain this first
issue that the defendant's right to
remain silent was what's challenged
basically
well that's right and the defense made
that objection when the prosecution was
asking rittenhouse about the fact that
well you know you you are tailoring your
testimony and have you spoken about this
before it's the first time you've talked
about this in this way
and ultimately the judge yelled at
finger again and said that this is a
constitutional violation and even if it
is the issue here for me was the way the
judge spoke to bingor i thought that he
basically told him that he
was supporting the grounds for mistrial
he didn't call a mistrial but he
definitely said that this was something
he thought he could do and he was going
to take it under advisement basically
yeah i feel like we're about to see a
mistrial in real time there julie the
second issue was about rittenhouse's
prior bad act at the cvs explain that
issue for us
yeah so prior to the trial the judge
made rulings there are certain pieces of
evidence indicating bad acts on the part
of kyle rittenhouse that weren't going
to come in unless someone opened the
door and in this case whether the
defense opened the door but here's the
problem
if you want to bring it out as the
prosecutor you got to ask permission and
so what he did is he just did it on his
own accord didn't ask the judge anything
and the judge said to him basically a
the defense didn't open the door and b
even if they had opened the door you
must ask for permission first and so it
felt like a bit underhanded on the part
of the prosecution to bring out a bad
act that he very well knew he needed a
ruling from the judge first and so
that's why the judge got quite angry
about that as well yeah and now it seems
like the judge is a little sensitive to
anything the prosecution does okay stay
put folks we'll talk again coming up on
law on crime daily after years of abuse
two members of the turpin family break
their silence in an exclusive interview
plus the trial for the death of ahmed
arbory our own brian buckmeyer is live
in glenn county georgia for an inside
look at wednesday's court proceedings
all that and more after the break
[Music]
and welcome back to law and crime daily
we look now to georgia where the death
of ahmed arboree trial is underway in
february 2020 arbory an unarmed black
man was running was gunned down while
running near his brunswick georgia home
he died as a result of his injuries
defendants gregory and travis mcmichael
and william roddy bryant face several
charges in connection with his death
including malice murder felony murder
and aggravated assault father and son
gregory and travis mcmichael tailed
arbory in their pickup truck as he ran
travis mcmichael eventually shot arbory
claiming self-defense brian followed
along in his own pickup truck and
recorded the incidents in this now
famous viral video after weeks of jury
selection opening statements began last
friday at the glenn county courthouse in
georgia and our very own brian buckmeyer
has been there since the beginning he's
live right now outside the courthouse
brian what is the latest in this
contentious trial
michael day four of the trial against
william bryant travis and greg mcmichael
for the death of ahmad aubry saw more
testimony of the facts leading up to the
shooting and the investigation that
followed matthew albenze the man who saw
maude aubry in larry english's
construction site testified that prior
to ahmad's death english showed him a
video of a person looking around and
walking on his deck that looked like a
mod aubry and on the day of ahmad's
death he called the police but not the
9-1-1 that he may have called but
instead he called a non-emergency number
because he did not believe it was an
emergency an officer testified about the
interview with william bryan describing
the chase of ahmad arbury aubrey's
fingerprints and hand smudges were
described as being on the sides of the
truck and kevin goff the defense
attorney for brian got out that brian
was distressed and unfocused during the
investigation during the lunch break
civil rights attorney lee merritt was
joined by benjamin crump and reverend al
sharpton discussing the makeup of the
jury along with how it broke their heart
to see officers check on the mcmichaels
as aubry's body lay their dying
all right obviously
we see there's some press conferences
there today with reverend al sharpton
with ben crump what were the the big
takeaways
the big takeaways were what the family
was reacting to as well as al sharpton
when he first heard about this case that
both the mcmichaels
were around
the scene of the crime and people seem
to be tending more to them than looking
after ahmad arbury
benjamin crump told us that he along
with lee mayor are filing a civil rights
claim against the county of glenn and
their police officers and the way in
which they handled this case at the
initial the exception of the the death
of a mod armory as well as attorney
jackie johnson who's facing her own
indictment charges yeah you know now
back inside the courtroom you you
mentioned there was evidence of these
smudges that were in william roddy
bryant's car and we hear arbor's family
had a big reaction to that what did ben
trump tell you
yeah so i actually got to speak with
benjamin crump one on one and he was a
little disgusted and said the family was
as well that when the defense attorney
was trying to make the distinctions that
these smudges or handprints were not on
the front or back of william bryan's
vehicle but merely on the side that that
suggested that he did not cut off a mod
arbory or did not try to run him over
with the vehicle trying to kind of
soften the blow so to speak that ahmad
abre was merely just i don't know
glancing by the vehicle or wasn't seen
in close proximity to the truck benjamin
crump along with the family uh kind of
took that in a sour no and didn't really
like how the defense was characterizing
what they said was very obvious from the
video yeah sometimes uh those efforts
pay off sometimes they backfire on you
hey brian thank you so much for the live
report from georgia we appreciate it hey
when we come back we're going to hear
from the turpin family survivors for the
first time since their rescue two brave
women speak out in an exclusive
interview detailing the abuse they
endured all at the hands of their
parents that's next on law and crime
daily
[Music]
and welcome back to law and crime daily
we're now hearing for the first time
from members of the turpin family
siblings who were subjected to abuse and
torture at the hands of their own
parents back in 2018 13 siblings were
rescued from their california home after
one sister escaped and made a 911
emergency call the 17 year old told
dispatchers one of her sisters was
chained to a bed and that she had not
been bathed in more than a year she also
said her parents claimed the children
attended a private school but at 17
years old she had completed only the
first grade at the time of their rescue
the siblings had been planning for an
escape for more than two years
in 2019 parents david and louise turpin
pled guilty to multiple charges
including torture and false imprisonment
they were both sentenced to life in
prison for the first time two of the
sisters tell their story in an exclusive
abc interview
my whole body was shaking i couldn't
really dial now on
because
i'm sorry i don't know how you had the
courage i think it was like us coming so
close to death so many times people were
chained for
what months
yeah
months
yeah unbearable
yeah
mother she choked me
and i thought i was going to die the
only word i know to call it is hell
how are these folks even surviving at
all julie the turpins were sentenced to
25 years to life
what are the chances they're ever going
to get parole
so i believe they're up for parole after
25 years um the question is after 25
years what's going to happen i mean you
know we think of murder cases and we
wonder is is this equal to that i'd say
it is these are kids that were
absolutely tortured for the most
important times of their lives they
didn't they were literally stuck in this
as she described hell um and so i think
it's hard-pressed for anybody anybody
including those children by the way who
are going to have a say as to whether or
not these parents ever get out are ever
ever ever going to think it's
appropriate to let them out of jail yeah
you know terry the turpins argued that
hey they love their children and
ultimately they pled guilty to the 14
counts of torture cruelty and false
imprisonment so how are you squaring
those two things
you know it's really hard to reconcile
those two things torture in california
is defined as intentionally inflicting
great bodily harm causing extreme pain
and cruelty and false imprisonment are
also intentional crimes so it's really
difficult to understand how you can
commit these intentional crimes and at
the same time
you are saying you love your children
either they are great liars because
those two things can't both be true or
in fact perhaps there was some mental
illness involved
we don't know whether or not that will
be a factor as far as getting out for
parole but frankly i don't see how you
can reconcile those two statements
because they are just complete opposites
of each other and frankly in my opinion
they do deserve to be in jail for the
rest of their life yeah very very
difficult situation so thank you both
julie rendellman criminal defense
attorney and co-host terry austin thank
you both thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we will see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
[Music]
you